[Música]
eu adoro quando as crianças dizem quando
eu era criança
e como eu ainda me considero uma criança
eu vou usar essa mesma frase
quando eu era uma criança eu tinha um
sonho eo meu sonho era ter um aquário
grande o suficiente para caber um
golfinho dentro como eu não tenho
nenhuma memória física desse tempo eu
fui pedir ajuda para o meu sobrinho o
joão pedro de 3 anos de idade
no começo ele ficou um pouco tímido não
sabia muito bem o que fazer então ele me
pediu ajuda
foi aí que eu peguei na sua mãozinha e
juntos começamos a desenhar o que foi
aquele sonho
e o resultado foi esse aqui logo ele
perdeu a timidez e passou a desenhar o
seu próprio golfinho
eu acho que esse golfinho está mais para
um boto cor de rosa ou um boto vermelho
mesmo o que eu não sabia é que isso
exatamente foi o que ele retratou no meu
sonho vivido durante a minha infância
passados alguns anos eu realizei esse
sonho mas ao invés de comprar um aquário
e eu construí um barco com a ajuda de
amigos e passei a viver no mundo natural
dos golfinhos botos cor-de-rosa e até
dos botos vermelhos o rio amazonas
mas esse não era um barco qualquer esse
era o barco íris o barco íris foi um
sonho esculpido em realidade com as
nossas próprias mãos
como não tínhamos dinheiro sá nossa
moeda de troca foi o escambo
trocamos apresentações teatrais por
porcas e parafusos conferências na área
de sustentabilidade por cordas e outras
ferramentas
também trocamos oficinas na área da
reciclagem por mantimentos e temperos e
foi assim que zarpam de coca
a região de francisco de orellana
consideradas portas de entrada da
amazônia
eram sete pessoas quando usarmos a bordo
do barco íris na verdade eram seis
pessoas e à mika a nossa cachorrinha a
nossa missão era compartilhar aspectos
da sustentabilidade com as crianças e
também com os adultos
foi assim através da linguagem da arte
que a gente conseguiu passar essa
mensagem sobre a sustentabilidade
nós também coletados em coletávamos
mensagens dos líderes das aldeias
indígenas e também das aldeias de
pescadores
essas mensagens eram todas depositadas
dentro de uma garrafa fazendo uma alusão
a como a gente se comunicavam
antigamente mas também como um sinal de
alerta sobre como a nossa maneira de
como nossa maneira de consumir neste
mundo está sendo muito rápida
michael reynolds é unb o arquiteto
norte-americano que eu admiro bastante e
ele fala que há materiais como pneus
latas e garrafas são materiais naturais
deste planeta
ele diz que se um éter chegar hoje aqui
nesse mundo ele vai encontrar esses
materiais circulando por aí muitos pneus
latas e garrafas
então pra ele esses materiais são
considerados recursos naturais
eu prefiro pensar que daqui a um tempo
esses materiais vão se tornar o seu
obsoletos e deixar de existir mas por
enquanto eu sabia que alguma coisa tinha
que ser feita com isso michael reynolds
também é considerado o guerreiro do lixo
e sendo assim durante a expedição bairro
íris pela amazônia
nós adotamos alguns guerreirinhos
guerreirinhos do lixo e passamos a
transformar os desejos usam materiais
descartáveis em brinquedos
mas chegou um tempo que eu já não sabia
mais o que fazer a minha criatividade já
tinha toda acabada eu posso passei a
brincar com as crianças de recife parte
e não sabia mais o que fazer com tantos
objetos porque aqueles lixos não paravam
de acabar
foi então que eu tive a idéia de contar
o conto para as crianças mas aí eu me
dei conta de que eu não sabia contar um
conto
então eu propus para a gente criar esse
conto juntos
a ideia era desenhar um pedaço de papel
os nossos personagens o a casa desses
personagens e o brinquedo preferido
deles e foi aí que surgiu o gato
borboleta
o boneco de lata e um pescador o gato
borboleta morava num barco no meio das
nuvens
o boneco de lata tinha uma casa de lata
no fundo do rio e o pescador até aquele
momento não tinha uma casa para morar
ele era morador de área livre na hora de
apresentar os brinquedos uma surpresa
todas as crianças desenharam armas de
fogo
ao invés de questioná las eu passei a
observar e interagir com elas então eu
também peguei um papel e uma caneta e
desenhar a minha arma mas aquela era uma
arma diferente ao invés de disparar fogo
bala destruição era uma arma que
disparava alegria arco íris era uma arma
mágica que também transformava todos os
recursos desperdiçados em mais
brinquedos imediatamente aquelas
crianças começaram a pegar várias
canetinhas e a colorir as suas armas
também e as suas armas também passaram a
ser armas mágicas
uma delas em especial disparou castelo
encantado do pescador de ilusão até um
elefante foi parar no meio da história
no meio da amazônia ea gente incorporou
esse elefante na história ele passou a
receber uma magia do gato boleta ea sua
tromba bem grande foi capaz de alcançar
o fundo do rio e assim limpa toda aquela
sujeira que por lá tava do papel os
personagens ganharam vida e passaram a
ser marionetes sendo manipuladas por
nossos tripulantes e por todas as
crianças
lá iam brincar com a gente do papel os
personagens também ganharam vida
novamente e passaram a ser as próprias
crianças brincando de fazer teatro em
escolas nas ruas nas praças e até no
imponente teatro amazonas em manaus
essa era uma época mil conturbada no
brasil onde milhares de pessoas também
foram às ruas manifestar a sua
indignação
esse foi o período de julho de 2013
antes devido barco íris eu vivia em são
paulo
aos 23 anos de idade eu já era
jornalista graduada e pós-graduada e
como muitos jovens daquela época sonhava
em crescer na vida
foi então que eu me mudei pra inglaterra
e desenvolve uma carreira como o tempo
fui me tornando o chefe de departamento
de marketing de uma universidade ganhava
cerca de 20 mil reais por mês e estava
muito bem mas foi quando eu fui passar
as férias na austrália que eu me dei
conta de que alguma coisa estava
faltando na minha vida eu passei a viver
num refúgio natural em uma das florestas
mais densas do mundo em nove islã
ao passear por aquelas florestas
de repente eu sentia o volume picando
até então não sabia que ele seria
aplicada da sustentabilidade na minha
vida mas algo tinha entrado no meu olho
eu tinha certeza e eu pensei que fosse
um dá lhe uma folha continue seguindo
uma de repente outra picada e eu me dei
conta de que uma sanguessuga tinha
entrado no meu olho
aquela sanguessuga estava literalmente
chupando o meu olho
tirando o meu sangue mas foi aí que tive
um estalo na verdade não era aquela
sanguessuga que estávamos subindo era o
sistema que eu estava vivendo e por mais
que estivesse vivendo não se um país de
primeiro mundo é continuava presa
naquele sistema capitalista se cheio de
erros
foi então que eu tive que tomar uma
decisão eu voltei para a austrália ou
desculpa sair da austrália voltei para a
inglaterra e de demissão do meu trabalho
vendi tudo
doei muito mais do que vende comprei uma
passagem e voltei para o brasil para
começar esse projeto chamado achou o
projeto adventures in search of nem tem
x sustainable future ou o código terra
aventureiros em busca de um sistema de
um futuro intencionalmente sustentável
nesse momento eu percebi que ao invés de
somente registrar o que as comunidades
intencionalmente sustentáveis estavam
fazendo eu também podia coexistir com a
natureza através das minhas mãos e
passei diz ser uma entrevistadora a uma
entrevistada enquanto as minhas mãos
estavam ocupadas puxando a carroça do
seu luís pelas ruas de são paulo
as minhas mãos também se sujaram de lama
ao pegar o barro misturar com a palha e
fazer um reboco de uma parede de uma
casa na patagônia
as minhas mãos também servirão para
plantar comida para as próximas gerações
sendo que eu iria sair daquele espaço
mas a planta é continuar crescendo
minhas mãos também pegaram em armas
brancas
ao participar de um mutirão na
construção de um telhado verde e foi
assim olhando por vieses e por janelas
se abrindo que eu comecei há realmente
viver esse futuro intencionalmente
sustentável que tanto queria
de vez em quando também dá um lance de
bicicleta no lixão e o lixão é um é uma
fonte de materiais que a gente usa para
trabalhar com um diversas construções
como aquela janela que mostrar pra vocês
o lixão é considerado um shopping hoje
em dia porque existe tanta coisa lá
dentro que as pessoas desperdiçam que dá
pra gente é aproveitar essa bicicleta
para o barco íris foi assim com um pulo
eu passei pelo brasil argentina chile
austrália chile peru bolívia equador
colômbia e quando eu cheguei lá eu
participei de uma conferência na área da
sustentabilidade
e foi assim que surgiu a idéia de
construir o barco eles o barco eles
então
saiu do equador passou pelo peru
colômbia brasil e terminam aqui em belém
do pará
a nossa ideia era sair dos grandes rios
e se juntar ao oceano de belém do pará
para são paulo
foi um vôo sem escalas eu saí da
amazônia para literalmente mergulhar na
babilônia
imagine uma lesma tentando atravessar a
avenida paulista em horário de pico
extra eu sendo reinserida na civilização
mas ao invés de criticar o sistema eu
sabia que tinha que fazer alguma coisa
então eu vestia um binóculos da
sustentabilidade e passei a enxergar são
paulo com outros olhos
uma das primeiras ações que eu tomei foi
contar esse conto através de uma
exposição fotográfica e se ainda falta o
meu pai vem do meu sonho de infância
esse golfinho dentro do aquário que
tanto queria se tornar realidade
meu pai foi também um dos 21 tripulantes
do barco eles e tenho muito orgulho dele
se unir vontades e chorar além de um
beijo para o mais perto que cheguei da
amazônia em são paulo foi à rua amazonas
e no fundinho dessa foto essas árvores
verdinhas que dá pra seguir aqui fazem
parte do parque da luz
o primeiro parque de são paulo e foi
através de uma palestra que eu dei sobre
a viabilidade de uma cidade sustentável
que eu descobri através dos parques a
possibilidade de trazer sustentabilidade
de volta para são paulo e foi assim
durante essa palestra que também
conhecia o parque augusta
o parque augusta é uma área de 25 mil
metros quadrados localizada no coração
de são paulo
uma formiguinha algo bem insignificante
para o tamanho de são paulo
não fosse o fato de que essa área é a
última área verde livre de construções
do centro de são paulo
e essa é uma área que está sendo
sufocada pela
população imobiliária esse é um pequeno
pulmãozinho do mundo que se espalha não
só no centro de são paulo
mas em outras partes da cidade e eu
percebi que esse não é um fato isolado
nem para o centro de são paulo nem para
todas são paulo nem pra outras cidades
do país nem para outras cidades do mundo
foi através da dona ana uma senhora de
83 anos de idade que naquela época recém
completado 80 primaveras que teve a
idéia de chamar uma série de atos em
defesa dos parques ameaçados de são
paulo
depois do primeiro ato nascia a rede
novos parques a rede novos parques hoje
já mapeou mais de 50 áreas passíveis de
tornarem-se parques na cidade e está em
conexão com várias outros movimentos
espalhados por todo o brasil
nesse momento eu passei a me sentir em
casa
percebendo que não só a rede novos
parques como outros movimentos e
iniciativas pessoas estavam justamente
em busca de uma rede para se unir uma
rede de confiança tentando aí
transformar o mundo uma rede de
confiança pelos direitos da mãe terra
essa é uma rede chamada casa o conselho
de assentamentos sustentáveis da américa
latina da qual eu faço parte e assim
como casa brasil existem outras casas
espalhadas pela américa do sul como casa
e pela américa latina também com a casa
méxico
a casa é o chile a casa colômbia existem
outras casas emergindo em outros países
da nossa região como república
dominicana ou uruguai argentina e por aí
vai
se michael reynolds é foi considerado ou
ainda é considerado o guerreiro do lixo
eu trago o exemplo de uma outra pessoa
inspiradora para mim mil morrem são o
pai da permacultura considerado por mim
o guerreiro do design de assentamentos
sustentáveis
ele costuma dizer que os sistemas
sustentáveis não são assim tão fáceis de
ser compartilhados por aqueles que
detenham poder
é a razão disso é muito simples permitir
com que as pessoas construam suas
próprias casas planta em seu próprio
alimento e gerem sua própria energia é
perder o poder político e econômico
sobre elas
então ele diz que dizia que a gente deve
deixar de olhar para essas estruturas
hierárquicas ou que o governo nos ajude
a idealizar formas de ajudar a gente
mesmo
é isso que eu chamo de alta gestão e tem
gente que me pergunta se eu sou algum
tipo de hip pós-moderna tentando salvar
o mundo com as próprias mãos para essas
pessoas
eu digo que cada pessoa tem uma missão
nessa terra ea minha missão pessoal o
meu código terra é o viver aprender e
compartilhar
qual é o seu código terra gratidão
[Aplausos]